oh my god you know beautiful well I was
nervous cuz you're here please but I was
like oh it might be cold they requested
it and we knew you're gonna be here I've
always loved your voice oh my gosh ditto
you can blow too busy there son I'm also
I'm covered a few of your songs on tour
like over the past 17 years or whatever
and your songs girl they are Reggie
[Applause]
thank you yeah I over complicate things
for myself live and then you get to the
torn you're like why couldn't I just not
do the octave I change it up a little
bit you're touring right now right I am
touring and yeah I hadn't toured before
that in like ten years cuz I why didn't
you Topher is it don't know like yes I
got really scared I'm like how do people
do this cuz I'm sure like I know kids
need like routine and structure like
bedtime the order and like how are you
supposed to do that whenever you're in
different time zones like every night
and things are changing so so hard it
was when I first had River in and then
we have two older kids I cried like
every night I was like this is so hard
it's so you know to be an absentee mom
and then you're offstage and it's like
oh the bedtime stories okay
what okay almost there to the other like
sing me a song and I'm like I just did
you're welcome yeah pay for it I have
everything cuz my daughter be like Shh
okay cool that to me let's sing and then
she'll go
like people they don't care it kind of
awesome
yeah it's great Marco you have care at
all no I love you know and I love that
actually I feel like we have similar
childhood speaking about parenting and
everything like I have make major
abandonment issues so like that's one
reason why I am like not a helicopter
mom but I really want to be here for
everything yeah you had kind of a normal
childhood but it was kind of hard right
y'all struggled a bit yeah it was a
chaotic childhood and lots of moving
we've moved lotta different places my
dad was in the army so it was like a lot
of shifting and yeah people ask me like
where are you from I'm like I was born
in Staten Island what I was raised
everywhere like Japan like everything so
um yeah Japan for three years yeah so I
just love Japan it's um isn't it I love
just so fun Tokyo yeah it's so beautiful
yeah oh my god getting the posters from
it but yeah it was amazing here I know
I'm not sure everybody's like wow oh I'm
not either
don't you feel like vain eccentric
Welkin social media was not around when
I'm soaking up I don't know how you do
it now it's kind of frightening to think
of where it's gonna be when our kids are
like yeah I'm not even giving them
phones like send a pigeon
yes I did feel at first I was like what
is this self like why do I want that in
my family get it I mean I get I feel
like it's like vanity run amok but I
know if I get into it I know I know yeah
but one of the reasons why I loved and
I've covered a lot of your songs
honestly is because for females you have
such an amazing catalog like your
empowerment level of females especially
it's so cool yeah and I and I know I've
just heard you speak a little at
interviews here and there just because
of a fan and we both have a little bit
of an emotional bringing as well as
financial and I think that's why it's so
powerful when you see those anthems
because you're believable I appreciate
you love your anthems authenticity is
very important to me with my music it's
partly why I'd takes so long to I can't
just take a song and and do it that's
like regurgitating not your truth and I
I made a decision when I made the
stripped album which was my follow-up to
the real good I saw that tour and what
were you been talking about you know you
give me chills and I and I the truth
yeah I will always wanted to be a truth
seeker and I felt like that was really
important to my fans too after strip I
really told my truth and you know sides
to all women that we are we you know we
shouldn't be apologetic if we have us
for our sexual side for our vulnerable
side through being a fighter and
overcoming obstacles I think those are
all messages that were really important
even though we're all different there's
room for everyone there's room for
everyone at the table tonight and that's
what I love about you too you actually
saying under dim ease a big Fanny Hill
did that song yeah I love that it was
really really cool but I have a question
so when I'm on tour I know that there's
always like one song that I'm still like
so excited about like I'm and funny
enough it's actually I had no idea no
one told me at RCA on my first label
this is true um I got my record and I
was like I'm going on my first record
and I'm like girl look at the booklet
and I was like I love Christina Aguilera
like what and so you wrote I didn't know
you wrote with red living and missing a
pin to it like part of that I didn't
know that because honestly no one told
me and I think this is the thing that
pissed me off is that's like why didn't
you tell me cuz I love her and I would I
would have been so excited in what they
told me is they were like well not all
females love to support all the other
females and I was like well let's get
rid of that and that's messed up
yeah I was so it's not couraging things
I think about this business is people
definitely categorized and pit you
against each other when you have like
even no idea that with males I know why
changing it
[Applause]
like on here like that when you go out
on tour you're like oh my god I can't
wait to sing this energetically what's
super fun is when the beginning opening
of dirty comes ok dirty and then the
vulnerability and the connection that
beautiful has with people when I sing it
it's such a relatable song and it's such
a truthful one to you know just
expressing your your insecurities and
being like well that's what I am and
accepting yourself all have insecurities
and we all have like it's funny because
that's what I wanted to do this show is
that we all have far more commonalities
the differences and that's one thing
that I feel like we should focus more on
because everybody so divided right now
and I don't understand but anyway I have
a couple songs that if you want me to
all mention I hate seeing them on tour
but what is one that you're like uh like
every time you get on stage you're like
good I could just do it again do you
want me to go first make you feel better
sure okay I didn't know if you're gonna
feel bad about it don't say miss
independent my band my band is here like
this with me forever
independent baby I'm not kidding it's
like super rocked out the version we do
on tour and it's my favorite and it was
my first so funny
but no the one I beat because it wasn't
for me do not hate me do not boo me I
will slap you I won't slap you cuz I
don't want you to sue me but but it's a
moment like this and only because Oh dog
do you gas but only because it wasn't
written for me it was written for the
winner and and it's so it could have
been anybody's and so I felt like it
wasn't like special for me Serena
what's yours um can I just say I really
love your setup oh thank you show had a
setup like this I did because of my
height like we're both short I wanted
pillows mind people because I know
girlfriends yeah what do I not like to
sing um hurt hurt is a big one Oh cuz
that's a big vote and it's all huh yes
like it's all extended vocals yeah
really you do some really great things
and your head voice is like legit my
face it's so pretty I'm just gonna
brownie is tomorrow I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this